europe's biggest nuclear power plant is
on the front line of the continent's
bloodiest war in decades after it was
attacked by russian troops
so is there an ongoing risk of nuclear
disaster in this conflict
this is the moment the zaparisia power
plant was shelled by russian forces
here's what you need to know about it
it's located here in the southeast of
ukraine around 550 kilometers from the
capital kiev and is one of four in the
country excluding the disused chernobyl
site
with six reactors in total it's the
largest in europe and one of the 10
largest nuclear power plants in the
world
it has a total capacity of 5.7 gigawatts
enough to power more than 4 million
homes gives ukraine around 20 of its
energy
the team of firefighters eventually put
out the blaze at the plant
thankfully only one of its six reactors
was operating at the time of the
incident but it was a close call nuclear
power plants are designed to withstand
all sorts of emergency scenarios but war
is not one of them
there are three potential ways that
conflict could risk a nuclear disaster
the first is a direct impact of the
nuclear reactor itself they are covered
with concrete structures which are
designed to withstand an aeroplane crash
and that was partly after actually nine
at 9 11. so um these things have have
been put in place but whether they could
withstand a missile attack i think
that's that's a great concern
this is what happened at chernobyl in
1986 a reactor melted down and caught
fire releasing huge amounts of
radioactive material
even in the worst case scenario we won't
see a repeat of this
a different reactor design the vver is
now used across ukraine
they're contained within extremely
strong steel pressure vessels and those
are contained within a concrete building
a second and more realistic scenario is
a reactor's cooling system failing
cooling water is vital to preventing
nuclear fuel in the reactor overheating
and leading to a meltdown
if cooling systems failed or were
deliberately targeted
worst case scenario would be similar to
fukushima's nuclear disaster in 2011.
here after a tsunami knocked out the
reactor's cooling system it released
significant but far less radiation into
the environment
finally there's the issue of spent fuel
once used to produce nuclear power
highly radioactive fuel waste must be
stored before disposal
thousands of tons of spent fuel is
stored in and around ukraine's four
operating nuclear sites and at chernobyl
[Music]
damage to sites containing that waste is
a risk
although it's non-flammable and doesn't
dissolve in water meaning any impact is
likely to be localized
it's not clear whether the russians
deliberately targeted the zaparisia
nuclear power plant a radiation leak
would be just as risky for invading
forces as it would be for local people
either way it's been widely condemned by
world leaders and organizations the
reckless actions
around the nuclear power plant last
night just highlights the danger of this
war this is a threat to european
security and stability and we need those
responsible to be held to account
the international atomic energy agency
has condemned the incident and its
director general today volunteered
personally to go to ukraine with a team
of experts to ensure ukraine's nuclear
facilities remain out of harm's way
[Music]
[Music]
you